david hasselhoff and anytime you hang
with the hoff
it's a wild ride and another et
exclusive
bye dave yep that's the hoff
multitasking in his new ad campaign for
pluto tv
we couldn't afford for our son to go to
college because of all the streaming
fees
now timmy's gonna be a lawyer thanks
kudo tv
it's the kind of thing that just it's
the gift that keeps on giving
how much fun was it shooting those when
i got on the set it was
incredible it was fantastic it was like
one take and i got it you know
you know especially the women you know
that was quite easy the kids have their
cartoons
the hubby has his sports and i have my
happy place hello
i'm david hasselhoff
i'm davida davida hot anyway i took the
wig because
it it was good for for halloween
david eden spoofs his days on baywatch
even a 24
7 channel starring yours truly oh my god
i run down the beach in slow motion
[Music]
because the slow motion was was only
because we ran out of money
do you stay in touch with pamela
anderson yeah baywatch folks
well we're doing a baywatch documentary
and they've asked me to try and stay in
touch with her
so i see pamela at the comic
you know e.t has been with the hawth
from the start check out this
in-depth discussion from back in 1989
about his
chest hair i shave every morning you
know actually i wax myself
yeah the hair is a little gray now but
um
on the chest but you know it was a lot
of fun
it was great fun wow
[Music]
would you be involved in rebooting
bringing in the next generation
of baywatch you never know i mean never
say never
and if you want a piece of tv history in
january david is auctioning off
some of his baywatch memorabilia for
charity including that iconic red
jacket and life preserver
[Music]
up next for the 68 year old a new tv
series that will start shooting this
summer but he's looking forward to the
days he can just say
life's a beach i've done the bay
baywatch i've done the night runner i've
raised the kids i've done that
now i want to just be a regular guy you
know
so we'll see what happens